金ちゃん肇社長です昔は僕ねあエフェクトばもう星発売の商品がデーたびに僕は毎回著
デビューしたわけなんですけど今回まだちょっと新しい p アンプが出たということ
で買ってまいりました
こちらグーン
であるやつは筋肉バックスば割の人が全てってパワーな人に目当てがかかれば行き2色
のさえは一人でお知らせください
チケットは守りましょうということでどんなには焼きそばで何か周りの人に迷惑かかる
みたいなをられるとやっぱり阿部たになるわけですよ
できる子はですねこのペン利益つはニンニク max チャージ人に見える
飾るのかどうかということで実際にこれは電車の中で食べてみようと思いますね by
こーよ
ダメでそんなことしちゃいけません落ちちゃダメなんでちょっとね
家で一人食べてどんな感じなのかちょっと感じてみようと思っても酔っぱできない
でしょうねよりは全然つ前提で作ってみますね
ああああああ
夕食計算町末社いっ
あの全く関係ない余談なんですけども実は僕今日からちょっとねに今週はちょっと
イベントのするなんで今日から実はでサンペイスタって youtube にベッドが
あって送られてる事務所のイベント牛ねっていうのが小島つねって他にないシネマ
ティックちょっとねイベントのねちょっと mc ってなことしなきゃいけなくて
大変と言うかちょっとでまぁありがたいいろいろイベントに出てね皆さんに会えない
とてもありがたいんですけどね普段の動画に時間が割けなくなってくるわけで今日で
かなとちょっとね思うように時間が取れてないんですけどもうねホント皆さんに会える
ということは何よりの幸せだと思ってます見てくださる皆様とかファンの方が入っ
初めて僕がねこの youtube を楽しめてるっていうところがあるので自分の
好きなことを動画にしてますと言いつつもやっぱりみてください皆様がいるのはとても
大きいことです
いつも見てくださる方本当にありがとうございますでこんな人の youtube
ファンフェスタという説とかね色んなイベントがあるんですけどもまぁ実際にあるなぁ
すごい嬉しいですしますね今後で
今回来れなかったという方もたくさんいると思います来年とかもぜひそうに着替える
作れて動画見てくださるだけでも僕はとても嬉しいんですけどもやっぱり実際にあって
ねうんん
バーン
これねいつもありがとうということで僕と直製缶機械だったらぜひ皆さん実際にやって
ね
喋りましょうみんな愛して競って本当にね
本当にありがとうみんな5入っていう話をしてうち33分くらい経ったかな
雪ヴィッテルは再定義で打ちゆきってきました
そんな酷いしなくね全然認めは普通なんですけどこれ人様に迷惑をかけるというかこれ
ね人様に迷惑をかけるって言ってるわけですがどれくらいの匂い官として俺はこの
ニンニクの臭いをまとったこれからイベントに行くわけですよ
もうイベントテロになりそうですね
わあああああなるほどあればなあきっと
お箸ないかなああこういうに良いか僕にあんまりネイトのニンニク臭いっていうのは
よくわかんないんですけども
ああああああっあっー臭い臭いぞいま
感じダメ羽鳥でニンニク臭いというものを見ようってくるんじゃな店を2人の放つ
放つプールこれらに具材っていうのはあっつ見た目だけ見て中でわかんないと思うん
ですけどもこれ
あいやこれ美味しいのかな
それじゃんでめっちゃ美味しかったら全然問題ないっていうねただ乳用品トンボねぇ
強いいただきます
me
部分まあ美味しいもしあの家まず両親が入浴剤ってやっぱヤバイちょっと危険ですね
otto otto がました
シャープがペアでおいしいおいしいですけどもは食ってる本人も食べにおいで鼻が
ツーンとするけどちょっとねありがとう今日は食べた家で寝に食べてみてくださいでは
私はイベントに行ってきます
私ももう少しなんですけどもね何もさ
味もまたね宜しくお願いしますというわけで感謝の気持ちよさにイベントに行ってき
ますじゃん
me
ん